but I decided to start a website you  know it's two to two days start a  website called commercial whaling New  Zealand put the website up two days  later the Sunday news called me not a  very reputable newspaper yeah I like did  an interview on the phone changed my  voice a little bit they then put that in  the paper and then this is how the cycle  happens and then the the breakfast TV  saw that and then just asked me for an  interview I guess now is the organizer  of the petition Jay Pryor Jay good  morning to you thanks for having me  who's your group  uh commercial whaling New Zealand is a  non-profit uh Lobby group that's aimed  to encourage debate and hopefully open  new zealanders minds uh to the idea of  commercial whaling in New Zealand a  non-profit group promoting commercial  whaling yeah absolutely yeah